Google cracks down on the right HR
McMaster under fire from the alt-right
Plus Chelsea Handler goes foe fascists
will talk about all of that and more I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh so many things to talk about first of
all I want to thank you our audience
you've now made us number one in news
and politics over in iTunes we're the
number one podcast and news and positive
our number two overall in the country
right this very instant which is pretty
awesome
if you go over and you subscribe and you
leave us a review right now there's the
possibility the pushers all the way up
to number one which would be awesome and
a testament to your your listenership
which we are always thankful for lots to
get to today we're going talk about
Chelsea Handler going full Mossi we are
also going to talk about the the Google
memo this Google manifesto that has been
making the rounds plus we will give you
the update from Trump world but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at texture calm so texture is all
about information if you're an
information adequately time and you read
tons of magazine magazines articles but
you don't want to subscribe to each
magazine it is really expensive to
subscribe to 200 magazine that's why you
get texture calm you can get up to 200
plus magazines full of in-depth
interviews and stories all in the
texture app things like time and the
Atlantic and Vanity Fair is an article
from the Atlanta me talking about on
today's show the last really good
publication Vanity Fair
it's got Sports Illustrated it's got
it's got all the publications that you
want all in one place plus their
archives
it makes magazines easy text your app
has gone just beyond just delivering the
magazine itself it made it easy to find
and enjoy the articles that you want to
read the make daily recommendations
exclusive interactive features videos
and more an texture is searchable so you
can mark what you like and check out
back issues view bonus video content and
they even curate articles and magazines
just for you texture calm /femme that
texture calm slash pen and right now if
you go to texture calm slash pen they
are giving my listeners a 14-day free
trial at texture calm so I spent so you
can try it out see how much you like it
I promise you're going to enjoy it
texture calm slash spend my wife's too
big Reader's Digest and she gets it
through texture calm remember to use
that flash pen so you get the 14-day
free trial plus they'll know that we
sent you again the app is called texture
and you can download it on any of your
mobile friendly apps and have access to
information at all times I realize my
brain is sort of like
Oh leech on information it needs
information at all times and that's why
I love texture comm go to texture comm
slash event okay so tons of things to
get to today as always I want to start
with this amazing story out of Google so
apparently a jury McGuire type figure
some Rando at Google decided to put out
a 10 page manifesto it's a 10 page
manifesto called Google's ideological
echo chamber and you can sort of imagine
Tom Cruise as the Google exec writing
out this 10 page manifesto xeroxing it
putting it in all of the boxes over at
the sports agency and then getting fired
that's pretty much what happened ok this
guy's random guy who's kept in his name
Anonymous he wrote this memo called
Google's ideological echo chamber and
then Google's vice president of
diversity integrity and governance which
is the most Orwellian title in history
Danielle Brown issued her own memo so I
wanna go through this memo because the
left has claimed this is just a disgrace
to Google it's just terrible how dare
this individual human being put out this
memo now what's hilarious is Gizmodo
which is a lefty site they say it's just
humiliating to Google but someone would
put out a document pointing out that
perhaps Google's pay disparity between
men and women is not due to
discrimination it's due to women working
fewer hours or taking different jobs
maybe it's due to the fact that less
women are fewer women are hired in tech
because there are fewer women at the
upper end of the of the bell curve in
terms of performance in tech which is
true you know perhaps it's because
that's the memo says and Gizmodo is very
angry at the memo so when they put up
the memo they omitted all of the charts
and links that were included in the memo
which is really quite gross if you're
going to include the entire memo you
really should include the charts and
links demonstrating that it's
substantiated it's not just some crazy
person some men's right activists
radical who's issuing all of this
information I want to go through this
because it's so moderate this particular
memo and the left is treating it as
insane anyway so this memo begins
remember it's all about Google which is
the largest company in the United States
I believe Google bigger than Apple I
mean those two are in a competition I'm
not sure but Google is obviously the
most powerful force on the internet
anyway and Google is very angry about
this so the guy from Google writes this
he says I value diversity and inclusion
I'm not denying that sexism exists and
don't endorse using stereotypes okay so
already we have started off with
somebody who's moderate okay this is not
somebody who's coming in
and just trying to shock okay this is
not feminism is cancer the memo okay
this is this is something different
since when addressing the gap in
representation in the population we need
to look at population level differences
and distributions if we can't have an
honest discussion about this we can
never truly solve the problem
psychological safety is built on mutual
respect and acceptance but unfortunately
our culture of shaming and
misrepresentation is disrespectful and
unaccepting of anyone outside its echo
chamber and then he goes on to explain
why it is that men are being paid
differently than women at Google and why
the employment is different and one of
the things that he talks about is
something that Lawrence Summers the
former president of Harvard who was
ousted for mentioning this this little
fact and nobody wants to talk about is
the bell curve when it comes to
distributions regarding math and science
so when it comes to men versus women
there are brain differences on average
between men and women there are
individual women who for who have
perform men their individual men who
outperform women okay that but we're not
talking about individuals now we are
talking about the broad scope of
humanity so we are really talking about
on average so if you look at the bell
curve of women the bell curve for women
in in the math and sciences is
relatively is relatively steep so it
looks something like this right and what
that means that there are a lot of women
who are close to the average there a lot
of women who are just below average lot
of women who are just above average but
when you get to the tails the tails are
very skinny is that means when you get
to the very very upper echelon of
performance and the very very lower
echelon of performance they're not a lot
of women there right most of the women
are in the middle more than what the
men's the men it's a shallow it's a
shallower bell curve so what you end up
with is something that looks a little
bit more like that so what that means is
that there are fewer men in the middle
the average score might be very close to
the same but there are fewer men that
are actually close to the middle and
there are a lot more men at the top end
so if the tail of that bell curve is
thicker for men and thinner for women
that means that if you were just to take
a cross-section of the bell curve all
the way out here at the extremes of
performance in terms of really high
performance or really low performance
you're going to get a lot more men than
you are women for every woman there will
be several men okay so when you talk
about a top company like Google that
means that on average you will probably
get more male applicants than female
applicants who meet your minimum
standards okay that's not a rip on women
that's not saying women are stupid that
is saying that women's brains function
differently than men's on average there
are areas where women dramatically
outperform and I believe spatial
differences is one of them there are
other areas when it comes to what
comes to anything having to do with
empathy and compassion women generally
outperform men on all of the IQ tests
but when it comes to when it comes to
math and scientists it's I mean this is
not sexist because it's just reality
okay this is one of those facts don't
care about your feelings moments the
bell curves for men and women do not
look exactly the same okay so this guy
goes on to the memo to explain this
he says Google's political bias has
equated the Freedom From offense with
psychological safety but jamming in
silence is the antithesis of
psychological safety so now he's making
my points when I make on campus all the
time whenever you talk about
psychological safety and you suggest
that differences of opinion are unsafe
well you are really doing is shutting
down people who disagree with you if you
are going to equate words and violence
then you're going to end up in this
uncomfortable area where somebody else's
words are violence to you this author
says the silencing has created an
ideological echo chamber where some
ideas are too sacred to be honestly
discussed and then he says differences
in distributions of traits between men
and women may in part explain why we
don't have 50% representation of women
in tech and leadership discrimination to
reach equal representation is unfair
divisive and bad for business this is
the case against affirmative action and
diversity screening and then he talks
about Google's biases
he says political orientation is a
result of deep moral preference and thus
bias he's considering that the
overwhelming majority of the social
sciences media and Google lean left
we should critically examine these
prejudices and then he goes through left
biases and he actually is taking this I
believe from Jonathan heights the
righteous mind so all of this is well
substantiated okay he's not just making
things up this is not just him trying to
be mean to women or anything he talks
about left biases being compassion for
the weak saying disparities are due to
injustice --is the right is biased
toward respect for authority disparities
are natural and just and then he says
neither side is 100% correct both
viewpoints are necessary for a
functioning society or in this case
company and they says Google's left bias
has created a politically correct
monoculture that maintains its hold by
shaming de censors in silence the
silence removes any checks against
encroach extremists and authoritarian
power it isn't one of the reasons a lot
of people have suspected that Google
bias these insurgent biases its search
results against conservative outcomes
and they may not even know they're doing
it right they may think that they are
just doing what is just and right but if
everyone there thinks the same way then
you end up biasing your search results
if your
YouTube Yuna banning particular videos
or restricting particular videos that
ought not be restricted then he goes
through the FAQs this particular memo
author I don't know who it is it would
be very ironic if it turns out to be a
woman nobody hilarious but what what
this guy says I assume it's a guy he
says that Google we are regularly told
that implicit unconscious and explicit
biases are holding women back in tech
and leadership so first of all implicit
bias test do not work okay implicit bias
training does not work implicit bias is
a bunch of crap there is no actual
connection in the social science data
between implicit bias you know those
tests they give you in your university
where you click on a black face and a
bad word or a white face and a bad word
a different rate that shows that you're
a racist those tests are absolute
garbage there's no statistical
significance to them they're non
replicable so you can take the test
twice and get it right the second time
and get it wrong the first time
that's not how any test is supposed to
work right every test that works you
have the same results if you take it
twice yeah but again the this is used by
the left as a club to be people innocent
we can't tell that you're actually
racist but we can suggest that you're
racist because of implicit bias right
you don't do anything racist but deep
down in the cockles of your shriveled
little heart we know that you're biased
and racist so the author says on average
men and women biologically differ in
many ways true sorry to break it to the
transgender and feminist advocates these
differences are not just socially
constructed they're universal across
human cultures they often have clear
biological causes and links to prenatal
testosterone biological males that were
castrated at birth and raised as females
often still identify an act like males
the underlying traits are highly
heritable they're exactly what we would
predict from an evolutionary psychology
perspective again this is true so in
terms of so he tries to explain the
disparities between men and women at
Google in terms of some of these
biological differences he says women on
average have more openness directed
toward feeling to nuts FedEx rather than
ideas these two they also have stronger
interest in people rather than things
they are into empathizing versus
systematizing and then he talks about
women have a harder time negotiating
salary asking for raises speaking up and
leading this is true ok all the social
science data suggests this now women
have higher levels of anxiety and lower
stress tolerance again this is true
according to the social science data he
says that men have a higher drive for
status men are driven by respect of
others women are not as much driven by
all of that which is why men go into
dangerous job for higher pay things like
coal mining and garbage collection and
firefighting and some for 93% of
work-related deaths and then he talks
about non-discriminatory ways to reduce
the gender gap he actually says okay so
here are some solutions if we want more
women then what we should do is we
should show we should make software
engineering more people oriented with
pair programming so that empathy matters
a little bit more he says that women on
average look for more work-life balance
so maybe we should start biasing toward
part-time work instead of full-time work
and he says that feminism has made great
progress in freeing women from female
gender roles the men are still tied to
the male gender role maybe if we allow
men to get out of that then that will
help a little bit but that does not mean
that we should have diversity candidates
it does not mean that we should lower
the standards for admission to Google it
does not mean that we should create
illegal discrimination absolutely okay
so all of this sounds really moderate
and fine I don't see anything that's a
problem here he says we should stop
suggesting that if you're against
diversity candidacies that you are
immoral we should stop alienating
conservatives we should confront our own
biases we should have honest discussions
about costs and benefits of the
diversity program again we should stop
at the microaggressions this is
microaggression training incorrectly and
dangerously equate speech with violence
is not backed by evidence and reconsider
making unconscious bias training
mandatory for promo committees again all
of this is fine moderate true right all
of it's fine there's there's really not
a huge problem here everything that he's
saying is well substantiated there are
links to all of the various studies
christina hoff sommers who's a feminist
scholar and who spends all of her time
studying this stuff basically signs off
on this entire memo and i want to tell
you what google's response to that has
been because it's really incredible
before we get to that I first want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Zeile so zero was one of my favorite
services Zeile is massage on demand they
come to your house they come to your
house with the table with the massage
oils with the music the whole deal they
turn your home into a spa it is cheaper
less expensive than going to your local
spot you don't have to make a
reservation like you do at your local
spa a week in advance you can get it
sometimes within an hour right Xero will
bring you same day in-home massages with
the best licensed and vetted massage
therapists right to your home you know
I'm big on the idea you know you
shouldn't have to spend a lot of money
to feel like a wealthy person and this
is one of those things where you don't
have to spend a lot of
to feel wealthy zeal makes that happen
for you it's becoming huge me I was in
New York the other day and I was seeing
people of zeal masseuses wheeling around
their materials all around the city this
is a big thing I've used it for my dad
I've used it for my mom my sisters my
wife I have used seal the masseuses are
really top-notch I mean we've we've used
several of them and they are all great
and and it's it's nine thousand licensed
massage therapists so right now they'll
get you started okay our listeners can
get $25 off their first massage by using
the promo code bend at checkout and
right now if you sign up for deals
massage membership you get 20% off all
your massages plus a free massage table
and sheet set they get to keep your
house $380 value that is yours free when
you sign up for the massage membership
there is no initiation fee to join the
membership just that great additional
savings on top of the $25 discount
you're going to get when you use promo
code Ben it's called ze e l ze e l comm
and I was trying to think actually what
to get my wife for her birthday I think
I'm going to get her a deal massage
she's the kneading a massage and zeal is
the best way to do it zo calm or you go
to their iPhone or Android app and make
sure you add promo code right there's a
little link this is the add promo code
make sure you use the check out Ben and
get $25 off your first in-home on-demand
massage and use that Benz that they know
that we sent you again zeal calm
terrific terrific service okay so how
does Google respond to this eminently
reasonable and practical suggestion that
maybe they should examine their own
biases with regards to hiring and firing
and elevations and the good of the
company so they send out their Orwellian
vice president of diversity integrity
and governance Danielle brown to issue
this statement quote Googlers I'm
Danielle Google's brand new VP of
diversity integrity and governance big
sister I started just a couple of weeks
ago and I'd hoped to take another week
or so to get the lay of the land before
introducing myself to y'all but given
the heated debate we've seen for over
the past few days I feel compelled to
say a few words what many of you have
read an internal document shared by
someone in our engineering organization
expressing views on the natural
abilities and characteristics of
different genders as well as whether one
can speak freely of these things at
Google and like many of you I found that
it advanced incorrect assumptions about
gender incorrect okay now we disagree
incorrect
again nothing in the memo ever said that
all women are incapable of science or
tech nothing in the memo said that all
women are incapable of working at Google
nothing in the memo said that all women
are incapable of advancing in tech
careers at Google the whole points of
the memo is if you're going to suggest
that systematic bias is at work inside
Google perhaps you ought to look at the
average differences between men and
women and how they act in the workplace
and what the average qualifications are
that is not an excuse to discriminate
against individuals that is an excuse
not to discriminate against individuals
because you shouldn't be discriminating
against people on the basis of Fantom
social justice warrior bullcrap okay so
this idiotic letter continues I'm not
going to link it link it here and it's
not a viewpoint that I or this company
endorses promotes or encourages so I'm
just going to send a nasty letter
without telling you what the underlying
material was diversity and inclusion are
a fundamental part of our values and the
culture we continue to cultivate oh boy
okay so diversity and inclusion except
for how you're sending a letter
specifically saying that this guy's
views are out of bounds and he must be
burned bombed him well throw him in the
river and see if he floats if he floats
he's a witch if he drowns he's not we
are unequivocal in our belief that
diversity and inclusion are critical to
our success as a company and we will
continue to stand for that and be
committed to it for the long haul as Ari
Balog said in his internal G+ post quote
building an open inclusive environment
is core to who we are and the right
thing to do
nuff said Google has taken a strong
stand on this issue by releasing its
demographic data and creating a
company-wide OKR on diversity and
inclusion strong stands elicits strong
reactions changing a culture is hard and
it's often uncomfortable screw you lady
I'm really sick of it I'm so sick of
this nonsense where people say well you
know us changing your mind it might be
uncomfortable for you
us you know taking your eyes and
propping them open while we show you
montages set to Beethoven's 9th that
might be uncomfortable for you as we
re-educate you I'm sorry it's
uncomfortable when Chairman Mao takes
you out to re-educate you in the ways of
communism I'm sorry if that's a little
uncomfortable it's only because you're
so narrow-minded and we have to broaden
your mind by force that's the only way
visit this tenant it's really nasty
we have to change you and it might be
uncomfortable for you well how about you
change okay maybe you're wrong is that
uncomfortable but can we acknowledge
that it's uncomfortable for you to
acknowledge some basic truths no it's
only uncomfortable for people you
disagree with and I'm sorry if I love
when people apologize if it's
uncomfortable for you you know like
you're torturing something I'm sorry
Ramsay Bolton to Theon I'm sorry if this
is uncomfortable for you you know it's
just a change you've had to undergo but
I'm really really sorry if you find it's
a little bit irritating or uncomfortable
it's harder on me than it is on you just
know that your horizons will be
broadened as we perform this surgery
upon you I firmly believe Google is
doing the right things as the VP of
diversity inclusion of BS and that's why
I took this job part of building an open
inclusive environment means fostering a
culture in which those with alternative
views including different political
views feel safe sharing their opinions
yes I'm sure Theon feels very safe under
these circumstances very very safe I'm
sorry it's uncomfortable for you we
won't link to your paper and you might
get fired here are you ready for this
that discourse needs to work alongside
the principles of equal employment found
in our code of conduct policies and
anti-discrimination laws you understand
what that means that's an over at threat
okay that is if you save these sorts of
things we may have to fire you you may
have violated our code of conduct that
says that you must never ever ever
circumstances mentioned differences
between men and women ever Emma we love
diversity sure and this will violate his
principles you shall be punished I've
been in the industry for a long time I
can tell you I've never worked at a
company that had so many platforms for
employees to express themselves I know
conversation doesn't end with my email
today I look forward to continuing to
hear your thoughts as I settle in and
meet with Googlers across the company
thanks Danielle hey Danielle how about
this you should stop being an
ideological fascist okay if you want to
provide some alternative evidence that
rebuts the presumptions created in this
memo you can do it but you are just
making this guy's point this guy's
entire point is that you're a bunch of
fascists who can't tolerate dissent with
regard to obvious obvious sociological
and scientific facts just terrible just
terrible and then you wonder why society
at large is so screwed up this is one of
the reasons society is so screwed up
because you have the quote unquote
great science advocates bashing the
quote-unquote science deniers over
things that are actually scientific just
ridiculous I want to get to another
element of the left crackdown the sort
of fascist crackdown that's happening on
the hard left
but for that you're going to have to go
over to Daley wire we're going to talk
about one of our favorite people Chelsea
Handler just a delight we're going to
talk about her and just one second we
got to go over to Daley wire for that
$9.99 a month it gets you a subscription
to daily wire the greatest of all
podcasts and the greatest of all
websites you get rid of all the ads on
the website you get the read this is not
just an audio show folks it's a video
show you get to see the brilliance of
this show unfold in real time magnet
check by just going over and subscribing
for $9.99 a month and you also get
Andrew Clavin show and you get michael
Knowles's show which is really charging
up the iTunes charts as well for some
odd reason people seem to like it so you
can get that for just $9.99 a month and
for the annual subscription you not only
get all of these magical magical things
get to be part of the mailbag on my show
and nolza show and Clavin show you also
get this the greatest of all mugs it is
legendary this this particular tumbler
leftist here's hot or cold it is the
grandness of all tumblers in fact there
are rumors that this is what led to the
war of the five kings in Game of Thrones
that they discovered this buried in a
cave and they uncovered what this year's
hot or cold mug and the Targaryen simply
could not allow the Baratheon to
continue to maintain it any longer and
thus they began a war left this year's
Hydra c'mon get that with the annual
subscription $99 ears a significant
discount off the nine nine nine month
that you would have to pay normally so
get the annual subscription get this
tumbler and be part of our team also
right now as I said earlier in the show
we are number two in all of tie tunes on
our podcast is number two in all
factions number one in news and politics
so keep the subscription and the reviews
coming maybe we get up to number one
which would be super cool
I would then you know have an excuse to
take my wife out to dinner which would
be happy for her and sad for me just
joking I like my wife but it would be so
make sure you go over and subscribe and
also leave a review we always appreciate
it we are the largest by far
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so speaking of the fascist tendencies of
the hard left Chelsea Handler who is now
she she was a second level bad comic and
now she has elevated herself to a first
level bad comic she is now up there
with Trevor Noah and Amy Schumer Lena
Dunham is sort of a comedian I guess but
Trevor Noah and Amy Schumer the top
three now are Trevor Noah Amy Schumer
and Chelsea Handler in the pantheon of
unbelievably crappy leftist comics I
would I would have put W kamau Bell on
there he's really awful but he's not as
offensively awful as these others are so
he remains second chair but those are
the three they're in a running gun
battle to see who is the worst comic of
all time in any case on Sunday two
Chinese tourists stood in front of the
rack stock building in Germany and they
made a Nazi salute why because they're
stupid okay so they're promptly arrested
because in Germany it is actually
illegal to do such things you're not
allowed to make the Nazi salute in
Germany which is I think is bad law as a
Jew I think that's bad law I don't think
that you should make that illegal I
think that you should use social shaming
to to you know fight back against that
sort of symbolic according to the
government a probe on suspicion of using
the symbols and anti-constitutional
organizations was opened against the two
Chinese men aged 36 and 49 obviously a
couple of morons they paid $58 fines and
they were released this however was not
enough for alleged comedian Chelsea
Handler who promptly tweeted this out
quote two Chinese guys were arrested in
Berlin for making Nazi salutes wouldn't
it be nice to have was here for people
who think racism is funny no that would
not be nice I'd be a violation of the
First Amendment as someone who
desperately hates racism hates
anti-semitism hates sexism okay I hate
all of these things I think they're
terrible I don't think it should be
illegal for people to express these
ideas because we live in a free country
and once you start policing what people
say with the government then you are
going to inevitably end up quashing
viewpoints that you find unpalatable and
those viewpoints may end up being your
own eventually one once the gun swings
back on you but another point for
Chelsea Heller who gets to decide what's
racist or not like for example let's say
there were a comedian who joked about
the race
of Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt skits
kids let's say that they joked that
about them being African in origin let's
say they did that would that be racist
should we prosecute that person what if
they joked like this Angelina Jolie has
filed for divorce from Brad Pitt he
wants the China she wants packs and
Maddox hashtag sorry couldn't help
myself
so first of all crappy joke but second
of all um should we jelly for that kind
of racist I mean he wants to China but
she wants apparently I guess the
Africans is that that what the joke is
supposed to be here because I believe
tax and addicts are from Africa are they
not
so that is or no where are they from
we're packing Maddox from I can't
remember are they from uh hmm you know
now I want to look up their ethnicities
but it is an ethnic joke I'm trying to
I'm trying to remember where they are
actually from are they Chinese where
were them now okay we'll have to look it
up the bottom line is it is a racist
joke okay so they are they are not from
the United States and and I let's say
they packed is is is Vietnamese is that
what this I think taxes Vietnamese and
so let's see Vivienne sorry I don't mean
take so much time on podcast looking
stuff up online but I want to make sure
that I get this right so so packs I
believe is Vietnamese and Maddox is um
he's from baddam bang which I'm not sure
where that is that vadym bang is in
Cambodia okay so one is Vietnamese and
one is from Cambodia okay so Pat so the
Chelsea Hellman makes a joke about
Chinese and Vietnamese people okay is
that exactly the thing is that a
wonderful thing no so apparently
according to Chelsea Handler maybe she
should go through jail also amazing the
fascist didn't stinks of people on the
left now there is this instinct for
people on the right as well I think
there's some all right people who have
the same instinct but it is a bad
instinct in it is something that we
should fight okay so I want to go
through all that because I think that
it's it's more important to the society
than the latest Trump news but let's get
to the latest Trump news so the latest
in Trump news is that President Trump is
on vacation for 17 days and that means
that HR McMaster
and general mattis and John Kelly are
not standing next to him taking his
phone away from him and hiding it under
the seat cushions and playing warm or
cold with
with the phone so he found his iPhone he
discovered the passcode and now he's
tweeting again about the fake news and
this and that he's got his phone again
but the bigger problem for him is that
on Friday it was announced that the the
special prosecutor rod Rosenstein well
actually said I'm sorry muller robert
muller impaneled a grand jury and that
means that they're going to be issuing
subpoenas about documents they'll be
issuing subpoenas to human beings to
testify about trump russia collusion
about financial matters and all of the
rest rot Rosenstein came out and he
obviously is trying to keep his job in
the trump administration he says that it
did what he says here is true though he
says impaneling the grand jury implies
nothing about about the indictment
itself does the fact that a prosecutor
takes a case to a grand jury what does
that say about the likelihood of
indictments Chris I'm you're right that
I'm not going to comment on the case I'm
not going to comment about whether
director Muller has or hasn't open a
grand jury you know you read a lot about
criminal investigations in the media and
some of those stories are false we just
don't comment on investigation so that's
important for a number of reasons first
of all we don't want to disparage
anybody who may be a subject in the
investigation number two we don't
interfere with the investigation but I'm
asking a different question what does it
say when a prosecutor takes a case in
general to a grand jury about the
likelihood of indictments in general
Chris it doesn't say anything about the
likelihood of indictments because we
conduct investigations and we make a
determination at some point and of
course the investigation about whether
charges are appropriate
okay what's the area obviously true and
it's good that he's saying it because I
think that it is important because the
entire left is jumping to conclusions
about this the right is jumping to
conclusions to and the conclusions
they're jumping to is that Muller hasn't
panel to grand jury to get Trump the D
that all he cares about now is getting
Trump
Alan Dershowitz who obviously knows a
fair bit about jury selection
considering that he was involved in the
jury selection for the OJ trial he says
that Muller looks like he's stacking the
grand jury against Trump as an ethnic
and racial composition that might be
very unfavorable to the Trump
administration so I see the significance
not so much that he impaneled around
here yapping pannel grand jury gets
being a power but where the imperative
that's an interesting point do you
believe that
it
kind of stacks the deck against the
president by doing that yes yes I do I
think it's a tactical move designed to
send a message that if the prosecutor
decides to prosecute he will have a real
advantage with the jury pool where the
case will be so provided there is
jurisdiction in his Columbia and it
would be generally jurisdiction almost
anywhere okay so you know he's
suggesting that the reason they handled
the grand jury and he see as opposed to
in Iowa is because they want this grand
jury to start bringing charges as soon
as possible against from that's not out
of the realm of possibility and I
respect Gershowitz his take on this
Maxine Waters said he was a racist
because how dare he suggest that race on
the grand jury means something and you
know again she doesn't know what she's
talking about because the fact is that
when you are looking at juries when
you're looking at jury selection of
course the race comes into accounts of
the people because you make assumptions
about on average black people are going
to vote Democrat more likely than white
people are going to vote Democrat so the
chances that you're going to get a black
juror on the grand jury who is the
anti-trump is higher just statistically
speaking you know all of this is a
danger to trump and it's a problem for
Trump the response from the Trump
administration has been that all of this
is phony phony phony and maybe hope
fireballer which would obviously be a
crisis we may be reaching breaking point
very soon with Muller which is a serious
problem here's Kellyanne Conway on I
guess this is ABC's this week talking
about how this Russian air that is
cheating the country and let me just say
something else about Russia the
president took on a new tack in West
Virginia speaking about this the other
night he told the people there and
around the country that those who are
pushing this phony fabricated Russian
investigation are cheating you the
voters out of what you clearly said you
want you want a new and different
direction you don't want the same fit
policies you want free markets you want
democracy you want national security
American exceptionalism prosperity at
home he's making good on those promises
look at the stock market look at the
jobs numbers look at the growth look at
the regulatory rollback on things that
were hurting taxpayers and property
owners and job creators and
and look and look at what he has
promised those people they voted for him
and it's Bob Muller is going to continue
an investigation will cooperate however
best we can but the president is not a
target of any investigation okay then
she goes on to say that Trump is not
going to commit to not firing a special
investigator if he gets too close to
something that to prosecuting if Trump
doesn't like it
bottom line Kellyanne drew the president
commit to not firing Robert Muller
the president has not even discussed
that if the president is not discussing
firing Bob Mollica will recreate not
refining and cooperating with he had not
even discussed not fire he's not
discussed firing Bob Miller to say hi
cob hold on I'm not the president's
lawyer here but I will tell you as his
counselor he is not discussing that okay
so she refuses about eight times and
that clip to say that mullah lumpy
pirates what we have here is a situation
where there is obviously a witch-hunt
going on from the left with regard to
President Trump I don't know that Muller
is engaged in that witch-hunt yet I
think that it's a little much to say
that Muller is obviously out to get the
president at this point I don't know on
the basis of the grand jury it will have
to see on basis the indictment if
there's some indictment brought we'll
have to look at the material in the
indictment and determine whether this
vet within the scope of the
investigation or whether it was actually
just a reach by Muller
I can't prejudge the product that I
haven't seen based on rumors that are
coming out that are unsubstantiated on
this side but what you have on the right
is jump to Muller that got to be fired
they would jump on the left to Muller is
going to take out Trump and then once he
takes out Trump then we're going to have
to take out Mike Pence that's what
Maxine Waters this nutjob the most
corrupt woman in Congress she says that
once we finish with Trump now we have to
step up and go after Mike Pence - we're
gonna go after everybody now remember
remember what they are hoping what the
Democrats are hoping they win back
Congress in 2018 and then they move to
impeach Trump and impeach pence okay
because how does the line of succession
go gang remember it goes president vice
president Speaker of the House so if
they were actually able to impeach Trump
and pence they won't be able to because
they they won't have enough votes in the
Senate but if theoretically they were
able to do so if there was some sort of
wipeout and Republicans lost the House
and Senate you could end up with
President Nancy Pelosi if that's not
incentive to go out and vote in 2018 I
don't know what is here is Maxine Waters
making the case president comes the
garden planning his inauguration is that
a joke or D rule it was a joke what I
wanted to do with needle bill a little
bit they canceled be better than Trump
if you were no and when we finished with
Trump we have to go and get Putin that's
our he's next Putin or pen a pen do you
mean
that will get two-for-one go jump then
we gotta go after that dress yeah okay
so I do love the I do love this crazy
old bat is doing the we have to go after
Putin we have to go for pence we have to
go after Newt Gingrich randos just and
everybody out there so the left is
suggesting that this is the end of the
world Trump is done the right is scared
that Trump might be done because the
mall are again not enough evidence on
any of this but it is opening up gaps
inside the Republican Party itself so
you have a report in The New York Times
over the weekend that people like Mike
Pence are now looking to step up for
2020 that Ben Sasse is visiting Iowa
that John Kasich god help us is is
visiting Iowa oh god no please God no
not John Kasich
he's coming out and campaigning against
Trump now they're a couple of splits in
the Republican Party that are worth
talking about because they continue
after the election one is the split
between the right and the so-called
moderates and the second is the split
between people who don't care about
Trump's behavior and people do care
about Trump's behavior I think that you
can be right-wing and care about Trump's
behavior that's where I am I think you
can be right-wing and not care about
Trump's behavior that's more like Dennis
Prager is you can be you can be moderate
and not care about Trump's behavior and
that's where Jordan Ivanka are
presumably and then it can be moderate
and care about Trump's behavior and
that's where John Kasich is the bottom
line is that just because John Kasich
says that he wants to run against Trump
in 2020 which is what he's going to does
not mean that the right is going to move
with John Kasich or the moderates are
going to move with John Kasich because
this is the weird thing okay Trump
actually crosses currents Trump is both
moderate on politic he's not
particularly right-wing he's much closer
to John Kasich on politics and to Ted
Cruz and he doesn't care about behavior
not like John Kasich but like a lot of
the right-wingers so he's got the
attitude of a hardcore right winger with
regard to the media for example but he's
got the policies that are much closer to
John Kasich
so when John Kasich says well you know
I'm going to run against him like on
what basis aside from being a wanted
piece of a wanted piece of receipt in my
pocket the one through the wash three
times here is Raisin in the Sun John
Kasich John Hickenlooper and I are doing
at the present is he's going to have his
staff and my staff and we've had
preliminary conversations because John
and I are becoming friends and they're
going to sit down and they're going to
look at the differences and one of the
problems is that there are some in the
Democratic Party that think the whole
cyst
needs to be changed at once and there
are some in the Republican Party that
say look let's let the market work to
drive down healthcare costs but we're
going to have to make a commitment a
serious significant commitment to those
people who are left behind so I think
Democrats are going to have to get to
the point where they say let's let the
market work if people more choice bring
down the cost of health insurance and
Republicans are going to have to admit
that there's going to be a group of
people out there who are going to need
help that these are some philosophical
differences between the parties but if
you have a good spirit and you
understand that I just go ladies go
ladies go away ok I'll just talk about
primary sitting Republican president
basically if your primary Republican
president even if you were to win the
nomination you're going to lose the
general there's never been a primary
challenger who is number one one I mean
that's that's incredibly rare you've had
situations like 1968 where the president
drops out like LBJ dropped out in 1968
but then his successor Hubert Humphrey
goes on to lose to Richard Nixon if you
if Trump is so bad that he ends up being
primaried and losing the chances they
become president are virtually nil so
Republicans are our width Trump boom or
bust
come 2020 to the extent that they want
to win a national election unless things
become so dire and so desperate that
Trump is just an utter disaster all the
way through and they're and they have no
choice so the splits on the right are
reopening in the wake of Trump not being
good at his job what's funny about all
of this is again in the areas where
Trump is not public in the areas where
Trump is not involved his administration
is going fine okay so there is there is
a story that just came out five minutes
ago that says that Donald Trump's
administration has now cut 11,000
federal jobs 11,000 of them in the last
in the last six months if the first
reverse in federal employment that's
happened in a long time that's really
good there's been reverse in regulations
right 16 regulations cut for every new
one added all of these are really good
things but that's not what people vote
on they actually don't vote on these
little things I know that people like to
flatter themselves that this is what
people vote on people don't vote on that
they vote on generalized perception of
the people who are running okay so with
all of that said the Democrats are in no
better shape right the Democrats seem to
seem to think that all of this is just
going to fall into their lap when
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
the polls right now have Democrats in
the generic valid up to plus seven but
they're it's a rather unconvincing
+7 because again a lot of the a lot of
the districts are either solid red or
solid blue so the question is what
happens in these very few purple
districts and the left is tearing itself
apart so Howard Dean he comes down he's
ripping the the Bernie Sanders wing of
the party at the same time they need the
Bernie Sanders wing of the party to win
there has always been a section of the
left which I Carla call as the the the
whiny party the party that doesn't
really want to win they just want to be
pure and if they go down swinging purely
then that's fine well the problem with
that is it leaves behind the people who
really need their help if we're going to
have a single-payer or Medicare for all
or whatever we're going to have in
health care that covers every American
as every other industrialized country
have been and we all have to pull
together and people who sit out or crank
on some candidate because they did this
or that it wasn't to their purity tests
are basically turning their back on the
very people they pretend to represent
just want to point out to dispossessed
Republicans that the same sort of splits
that are happening inside the right are
happening inside the left Jerry Brown is
the delusional Governor of California
he thinks that they're going to swing
left and the Democrats going to a broad
victory by the way Jerry Brown still
wants to run for president he's 1,000
years old
we actually exhumed him to make him
California California's governor again
here's turned round talking about what
he thinks is going to happen in 2018
historic turned when Lyndon Johnson won
overwhelmingly against Goldwater people
were writing and I read it at the time
that the Republican Party was gone and
then it comes back and the Democratic
Party comes back so the nature of our
business is that swing of the pendulum
and it's definitely already swinging
back toward a non Republican kind of
future we hope based on general trends
we'll win we only have an affirmative
case for why we should and also I don't
know where I am why I'm here who you are
why I'm talking or I think I beat myself
Governor Jerry Brown thank you okay so
bottom line is there is chaos inside
both parties to suggest otherwise is to
be ignorant of how the Republican Party
is working and also how the Democratic
Party is working that means it will
alignment is happening but I don't think
the realignment is inside the Republican
Party or inside the Democratic Party I
think the realignment is largely a bunch
of people who are dispossessed with both
parties and are just looking for people
who are reasonable to follow or vote for
in any case okay time for some things I
like in some things I hate
so things I like first of all I want to
thank again Joe Rogan for having me on
last week it was a really fantastic
thing and Joe is great I thought the
conversation was really good if you
haven't you go over and check out the
podcast that I did with Joe last week a
really good conversation with two and a
half hours two hours for tea and we went
through a number of topics everything
from environmentalism to transgenderism
to free speech and I think that when I
talk about this sort of new center
that's forming I don't think it's the
center in terms of political outcome I
think it's the center in terms of people
who actually want to hear reasoned
argument and recent debate as opposed to
a bunch of people who just get on your
TV and talk about Republican versus
Democrat all the time okay other things
that I like so I've decided to do expose
zuv communism and socialism last week I
talked a lot about what's happening in
Venezuela it continues to break down in
Venezuela there was supposedly a
terrorist attack that is causing the
president of the dictator of Venezuela
to crack down on his opposition again
this looks again a lot like virtually
every dictated dictatorial crackdown it
looks like the coup that happened in
Turkey that failed or the fake food that
happened in Turkey so low know what that
was it allowed air21 to maximize his
power here is a book it's probably the
best book ever written on communism that
no one has ever read it's considered one
of the top ten novels of all time but
very few people have read appease is
very very short
it's called darkness at noon by Arthur
Kessler and it's all about a really
Trotsky figure who was part of the
Russian Revolution and now has been
imprisoned and it's awaiting his and his
waiting - carrying out of his death
sentence and sort of the thoughts that
are going through his head him becoming
disillusioned with the cause he spent
his entire life fighting for really dark
really terrific short very short read
very readable darkness at noon by Arthur
Tesla they tried to make a movie I think
at one point but it's more of a
psychological novel than anything else
so not not doesn't really lend itself to
moviemaking as much as it does for for a
read but it's a great kind of almost
forgotten classic darkness at noon okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
so a couple of things that I hate so
Kellyanne Conway was asked on one of the
sunday shows about president Trump's
transgenders and military bands you
recall a couple of weeks ago that Donald
Trump tweeted out almost seemingly out
of nowhere that transgenders would no
longer be allowed in the military and
there are people like me who said I
generally agree with the policy but I
would like to see general mattis lay it
out I'd like to the military I'd like
see what the Pentagon does I want to see
their opinion on this I want to see them
lay it out in the most free and full
fashion so we can have a good open
debate about it and see what the
rationales are and Kellyanne Conway is
asked okay so Trump tweeted this was the
military even aware that he was doing
this and here's what she had to say just
did the chairman of the Joint Chiefs did
this defense secretary did the
Commandant of the Coast Guard did the
other service chiefs sign off on that
policy on that tweak before the
president sent it out I can't answer
that because I wasn't in the room when
they discussed it with him and I was and
I certainly are on the National Security
Council but I will tell you in having
spoken with the president directly about
this and having been involved a little
bit in the discussions that the
president had consulted for quite a
while with different stakeholders
including his generals what he says in
the tweet is absolutely true he
consulted with generals and others about
this issue
okay so again here is the problem then I
said this at the time how you do things
is just as important as what you do if
you do it wrong you end up actually
backfiring so what's happened now is the
Pentagon has said we have to had no
specific instruction from the White
House we are not carrying out anything
without any sort of plan or specific
instructions so Trump just tweeted
something out toxified it in the public
discourse and then threw it on his
military which promptly ignores it this
is not how policy ought to be done if
Trump wants good policy implemented he
should do the same thing he's doing with
regulations and with employment he
should just let his chiefs take care of
it okay they know what they're doing
when it comes to the specifics of this
stuff he does not let him be the face of
it let them develop the policy and let
him pitch it but he has to understand
that he ought to be doing exactly what
he did on the apprentice okay
he's the pitchman he is not the idea
creator nor was he the implementer okay
other things that I hate so this is just
a weird thing Kaylee mcenany who's been
a pro Trump member of the Trump campaign
she was on CNN and now she's no longer
on CNN
you popped up on something they're
calling Trump TV which is from the White
House apparently and it is it is Donald
J Trump calm and it is her bringing you
real news not fake news real news hi
everybody I'm Kaylee McInerney thank you
for joining us as we provide you the
news of the week from Trump Tower here
in New York more great economic news on
Friday to July jobs report added a
better than expected 209 thousand jobs
overall since the president took office
President Trump has created more than 1
million jobs the unemployment rate is at
a 16 year low and consumer confidence is
at a 16 year high all while the Dow
Jones continues to break records
president Trump has clearly scared the
economy back in the right direction I
didn't like the one who vomited this is
not new everybody treating like this is
new ok Obama if you recall actually for
a wild man pressed photos and was only
issuing White House press photos so this
is a centralization of the communication
strategy that I just do not like from
either side okay I understand is why you
have a White House press office this is
why you have allies in the press but
this idea they're going to have
state-sponsored TV to back the president
I didn't like it when I was Obama I
don't like it when it's Trump I don't
appreciate it and I think that Kalyan
mcenany is better than that she's
obviously smarter she's obviously
talented working for Trump TV seems to
me a misuse of those talents especially
because you're not going to get real
newsroom get Trump's news which is fine
that's fine but I think that you know
having it openly sponsored by the White
House is a little bit much okay so we
will be back here tomorrow with all of
the latest news again make sure that you
leave us and go subscribe leave us a
review and make sure also that you give
a listen to Michael Moses brand-new show
you can get that at iTunes that is also
doing really well in the news and
politics section over in iTunes it's fun
to listen to also Andrew Clavin the show
is coming up next to make sure that you
go over to iTunes and subscribe to that
as well as Ruth show has been fantastic
for a long time and it is always a well
informed and funny take if you've never
listened to it go give it an intro
Clavin show a listen we don't agree on
everything Trump related but it's it's
really wildly entertaining so go check
it out Andrew Klay the show okay we'll
be back here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
you